cardi b
singing a shakira classic yeah we can
get behind this cover
big big things on the way big bangs on
wednesday cardi b
showed everyone how she practices
self-love taking a moment to appreciate
her pregnant body
oh yes honey last month the rapper
stunned the audience at the bet awards
revealing that she was pregnant with her
second child with husband
offset and now she's channeling shakira
to celebrate her maternity physique
[Music]
cardi shared this moment to her
instagram story singing
a short and sweet cover of hips don't
lie do y'all see how this baby got my
[ __ ] hips
you know my hips don't lie cardi then
joked that she wasn't getting enough
feedback from the room
but she knows where her hubby stands
anyway you like my buddy
i love your buddy hey for real
you like it fine then austin likes it
the couple just celebrated their
firstborn's third birthday
throwing culture a fairytale-themed bash
on saturday
happy birthday happy birthday
happy birthday yep
that's the birthday girl arriving to the
party and a literal carriage ride
you're so beautiful her parents went all
out for the affair
with multiple princess performers around
to spread the magic
on her big day
oh my god i want to cry
following her pregnancy reveal cardi
shared her prediction for what kind of
big sister culture will be
pointing out that her first born will
have the same age difference as cardi
and her younger sister hennessy i don't
know i just
get too emotional when it comes to my
kid she wrote on instagram i just know
these two will love each other so much
and argue so much since they're three
years apart just like me and henny
but one thing for sure is that they'll
have each other's back like no one else
ever will
cardi is also celebrating her upcoming
appearance on normani's latest single
wild side i'm so excited you guys are
gonna see
like normani in a different
light oh my gosh i'm excited perhaps
this was cardi returning the favor
last year normani made a cameo in the
music video for [ __ ]
i feel like this is normani big comeback
and
like i want you guys to treat it like
it's her birthday
and cardi isn't hiding her excitement
about their new collab
this song this everything is amazing and
i'm just so proud of her
uh i'm just like the the support team
you